(light festive music)
♪ Sisters, sisters ♪
♪ There were never such devoted sisters ♪
♪ Never had to have a chaperon, no sir ♪
♪ I'm here to keep my eye on her ♪
♪ Caring, sharing ♪
♪ Every little thing that we are wearing ♪
♪ When a certain gentleman
arrived from Rome ♪
♪ She wore the dress and I stayed home ♪
♪ All kinds of weather ♪
♪ We stick together ♪
♪ The same in the rain or sun ♪
♪ Two different faces ♪
♪ But in tight places ♪
♪ We think and we act as one, ahah ♪
♪ Those who've seen us ♪
♪ Know that not a thing
can come between us ♪
♪ Many men have tried to
split us up but no one can ♪
♪ Lord, help the mister ♪
♪ Who comes between me and my sister ♪
♪ And Lord, help the sister ♪
♪ Who comes between me and my man ♪
(light festive music)
♪ Sisters ♪
♪ Lord, help the mister ♪
♪ Who comes between me and my sister ♪
♪ And Lord, help the sister ♪
♪ Who comes between me and my man ♪
♪ Sister, don't come
between me and my man ♪
(audience cheering)